alors je m'appelle benoît berger alors
jusqu'à quand ces cours
c'est qu'ils
disent qu'à caen d'abord c'est la figure
de son de son leader c'est pour moi
c'est gilbert pounia
au delà des gilbert pounia c'est comment
on l'a rappelé ce soir c'est un ensemble
c'est une démarche globale culturel
musical qui m'intéresse avant tout la
musique n'étant pas créole j'ai eu à
batailler un petit peu pour comprendre
les textes et rentrer un peu dans le
dans le sens et ce qui m'a d'autant plus
intéressé je me suis reconnu dans
certaines
valeurs que le groupe véhicules et donc
c'est un tout c'est la musique c'est la
voie de
de gilbert c'est l'ensemble et puis les
expériences qui m'intéresse beaucoup et
n'étant pas dit si c'est cette ouverture
d'ouverture sur l'afrique madagascar
l'europe donc voilà en tant que musicien
puisque c'est mon métier aussi je me
retrouve complètement et puis joue je
pense et je suis pas le seul d'ailleurs
la soirée de ce soir le prouve que c'est
le groupe emblématique de la réunion
aujourd'hui
alors mon titre préféré c'est pas un des
plus connus c'est forme quatre couleurs
parce que ça parle de l'etang-salé nous
je réside et puis c'est une chanson que
j'ai repris aussi à ma façon et que je
jamais mme d'autres mais c'est l'aele
j'en ai une autre si que j'aime beaucoup
qui s'appelle sangatte sangles qui est
pas des plus connus parce que je connais
aussi personnellement l'auteur de ce
texte qui s'appelle serge de lantin et
c'est un texte magnifique et je trouve
que dans cette chanson là gilbert pounia
chante particulièrement bien
alors mon lien existe quatre ans et que
ba gg au bout de dix ans de présence à
la réunion j'ai
j'ai croisé parfois des gens qui faisait
partie du groupe je suis client assez
assidu du zanzan le
ou la famille poulin se produit j'aime
beaucoup maya kamati
et puis voilà je connais personnellement
des gens qui ont fait partie de
l'aventuré qui sont des gens très
proches et qui mois initiée presque à
disques à caen qui m'ont fait découvrir
effet aimé fait mais ce groupe
je sais pas s'ils ont
transformé la société réunionnaise mais
je pense qu'ils ont servi un peu de
bois ils ont un peu comme des gens qui
aurait éveillé un petit peu les
consciences ou en tout cas ils ont porté
le
une parole très intéressante en créole
en plus pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas
créole je trouve qu'ils ont donné cette
ouverture là de pouvoir accéder à cette
pensée créole et à cette langue créole
de façon assez
intelligente et subtile et ouverte et
moi ça ça m'a tout de suite plu bien sûr
la musique
moi je ne me pose pas cette question
c'était un moulage
en fait ça m'importe peu de savoir si
ses contemporains n'ont pas ce qui
m'importe c'est que ça existe et que ce
soit que ce soit
vécue pour des gens comme moi encore une
fois je parle en mon nom à titre
personnel je trouve que c'est c'est une
approche d'ouverture et c'est une
approche une approche globale culturel
qui me plaît donc en tant qu'artiste
même si modestement artistes je trouve
que c'est très intéressant alors est-ce
que ses contemporains est-ce que c'est
presque curseur est ce que c'est
révolutionnaire je pense que pour
l'époque oui ils l'ont rappelé ce soir
j'ai appris des choses d'ailleurs ce
soit je pense que ce qu'ils ont fait il
ya 40 ans c'est un moment très fort
oui ça c'est assez rare
qu'on en parle ça sert à ça ça serra a
donné l'envié à plein de gens de faire
de la musique à plein de jeunes de faire
de la musique j'étais enseignant jusqu'à
l'an dernier puisque j'ai démissionné
j'ai j'ai vu à travers
les écoutes que j'ai pu faire de cette
musique avec les marmailles que oui ça
allait toucher aussi bien sûr c'est
important